بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجين لانه نرحب بك طبعا العميد
الياس حنا وقراءه عسكريه واستراتيجيه فيما
يجري الان من تطورات في اوديسا فيما يصفه
المراقبون بحرب الحبوب في
ازدهار هناك مسارين اساسيين اليوم نتحدث
عن الكوريدور الانساني هو فقط حسب ما
اعتقد لخروج السفن التي كانت عالقه في
اوديسا باتجاه دولها والممر الثاني هو
لتصدير الحبوب من اوديسا برا الى مرفع
اسماعيل بعدها عبر العبارات الى الدانوب
اقصد نهر الدانوب الى رومانيا ومن ثم
اخراجها في هذا الاطار حاولت روسيا
الاسبوع الماضي ان تعترض سفينه تحمل علم
بلاو باتجاه اوديساء وكانها ارادت ان تضع
قواعد اشتباك جديده او تقول انا موجوده
فاذا انا اقول ماذا يحصل وكانت المقاربه
سلميه ولم تكن عسكريه كما هددت في بدايات
الخروج من اتفاق القمح ازدهار لكن موسكو
من جانبها التنفي استهداف البنيه التحتيه
لهذه الموانئ الاو وتتحدث عن استهداف
مواقع ذخيره ومسيرات اوكرانيه
سفيان عندما نتحدث عن الاتهام بالسفن بنقل
سلاح الى اوكرانيا هذا الامر اعتقد بعيد
عن الواقع او العقلانيه لماذا لانه انت
عندما تريد ان تنقل فعلا سلاح ذات قيمه
عاليه هناك الممر اللوجستي المفتوح عبر
بولندا وياتي من اوروبا ومن هناك تاتي هذه
الاسلحه اليوم عندما نتحدث عن مسيرات عاده
المصانع لا توضع على الجبهه الاساسيه لصنع
المسيرات قد يكون محق الوزير شويغو عندما
قال انها يمكن ان يكون هناك من ادسا
انطلاق المسيرات البحريه السطحيه لاستهداف
اما السفن المدنيه
حملت النفط او العسكريه او حتى جسر هو محق
في هذا الامر
ماذا عما يجري في زفروجيا ومتابعتكم
العسكريه لما يجري فيها خاصه اعلنت عن
استهداف هذه المنطقه وايضا مناطق اخرى
كمقاطعه كالوجا بريانسك وتعرضهما لهجمات
امر مختلف تستهدف خمس مرات خلال شهر واحد
اليوم عندنا نتحدث عن موسكو ازدهار لموسكو
تاريخ يبدا يعني منذ الحرب البارده وحتى
جهاز دفاع تم تفعيله بالعام 99 هناك
دائرتين للدفاع عن
روسيه او العاصمه موسكو منها ما هو مخصص
كانت قديما لصواريخ النوويه ومنها ما كان
مخصص لصواريخ الاقل اهميه هذه الصواريخ
صنعت في مرحله لم يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار بها
للمسيرات وفجاه بدات المسيرات وعاده
للتاقلم مع كيفيه ضرب هذه المسيرات هذا
الامر يستلزم وقت اساسي اما على الجبهه
الاساسيه بطول 900 كم الازدهار هناك هجوم
وتقدم يبدو في
سيلكا الى
مدينه بسيطه تقدم فيها جيش الاوكراني وهي
الطريق التي تفتح الباب باتجاه بيرديانس
التي تطل على البحر ازوف ولكن لا نزال في
هجوم اوكرانيا
الخبير العسكريه والاستراتيجي شكرا جزيلا
لك